one other note on Marjorie Taylor green
Mike pillow
his real name is Mike Lindell he's the
CEO and founder of my pillow Mike pillow
seems to be turning on Marjorie Taylor
green and this is the continued Rift
within the pro-trump wing of the
Republican party and pillow is not happy
with Marjorie Taylor green over her vote
for Kevin McCarthy and says she was
probably bribed with some kind of
promise for something take a listen to
this and then you just think of this I
want you to think of this look when Matt
Gates put this out okay and what seven
was it the seventh or eighth vote now
think of this if you did it right out of
the gate you got to think of this as
marketing guys you know if you did a ray
of the gate it's not going to fly you I
think right now it's happening just the
way it's gonna unfold here where does
this end it can only end with McCarthy
giving in it's not going to be the other
way and I'm telling you that I know
these guys uh if it if they if they have
made promises to the Grassroots they
made promises to the people Matt Gates
is not going to make you break his
promise and neither I'm very surprised
that the one I won't name her name but
it's Marjorie Taylor green for promise
oh I let it slip out yeah the media can
say Mike Lindell bashes Marjorie Taylor
green
yeah
that she uh I mean it's her choice but
obviously she was promised something
yeah so listen people get promised stuff
all the time pillow is not wrong that
there's all sorts of horse trading and
promises and and that negotiation a
hundred percent that's the case the
message here though is when you've lost
Mike pillow but you are pro-trump that
is a serious Rift and of course the hope
is that this degrades and and destroys
the Republican party from within the
most important aspect to this that I
think it's important to refresh is that
at no point were these 20 Republicans or
the others were none of them at any
point were primarily concerned with what
is best for the American people they
were concerned with publicity they were
concerned with attention some of them
were probably concerned with staying in
Trump's good graces they were concerned
with all sorts of different things what
can I negotiate for myself how can I
seize power for myself what was not on
the list is what is best for the
American people it was not even a
consideration they turn on each other
they turn back their friends their
enemies you look at Dan Crenshaw you
look at Matt gates are they with Trump
are they not they disagree here they
agree there whatever
but never does it enter into the cons
into the calculus
what is best for the American people
here and the proof continues to be
presented in the reality that after they
finally agreed on a speaker after 15
votes and Kevin McCarthy took the gavel
and the whole thing
the first thing they went to was
repealing the funding bill for the IRS
which by the way they don't understand
they're confused about and also has zero
chance of even becoming a reality
because the Senate's not going to repeal
it and if they try to Joe Biden would
veto it it's going nowhere it's just a
waste of time
the idea of hey what did the American
people need
what might be useful to the American
people why don't we look at health care
and getting people Health Care why don't
we look at education why don't we look
at climate why don't we look at energy
why don't we look at all these different
no it's just what about repealing the
IRS thing which we don't even understand
they do not care about the American
people and much like you know we had
these viral interviews and Luke Beasley
would do some for us at Trump events he
would ask people what do you like the
most about what Trump did
and the answers were either something
Trump didn't actually do or something
Trump did that has absolutely no impact
on their lives whatsoever or has a
negative impact give it six months now
of Republican control in the house give
it a year and then we'll go out and
interview these very same people and say
what is the Republican house done it
will either be things they haven't done
things they did that are damaging or the
third one that you're going to see as
well they haven't been able to do
anything because of Democrats in the
Senate that's going to be the
explanation we're ready for it it's
unfortunately very depressing
one of our sponsors today is zipx
nicotine toothpicks zipx brings you a
convenient alternative to smoking and
vaping and The Vape clouds the ashtrays
the thing in your lip that people can
see I've seen that around this is an
easier and less messy way to curb the
cravings and you can use zipx just about
anywhere zipx is available in six
flavors with two or three milligram
strength the nicotine and the flavor are
long lasting and zipx has helped
countless people kick the bad habits and
they are bad habits zipx toothpicks are
FDA registered their customer service is
second to none it is one of the most
cost effective Alternatives also check
out their B12 and caffeine toothpicks
see for yourself why so many people have
switched to zipx 2 picks you can only
get zipx online go to zipxtoothpix.com
and get 10 off with the code Pacman the
link is down below